Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I've got to go, Rock. It's all right. I'm not afraid. Sometime, Rock, when the team is up against it, when things are wrong and the breaks are beating the boys, ask them to go in there with all they've got
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我得走了，罗克。没关系。我不害怕。总有一天，罗克，当球队陷入绝境，当事情不顺且接连受挫时，请告诉他们全力以赴
and win just one for the gipper i don't know where i'll be then but i'll know about it and i'll be happy that dominic sandbrook was the death of george gip who originally was a very successful basketball player, then became a football player after his team coach saw him kick football an absolute mile. He was a great football star. And then very sadly, he got a throat infection and died of it at the age of 25. But the twist in this story, and people may be wondering why we're talking about this rather obscure football player, the twist, as I'm sure all our american listeners will certainly know is that actually that wasn't george gip that was ronald reagan playing george gip right and that was original footage was it
为吉普再赢一场。我不知道那时我会去哪里，但我会知道的，我会很高兴多米尼克·桑德布鲁克就是乔治·吉普的死因，他最初是一名非常成功的篮球运动员，后来成为一名美式足球运动员，因为他的球队教练看到他将足球踢出了绝对超远的一段距离。他曾是一位伟大的美式足球明星。然后非常不幸的是，他感染了喉炎，并在25岁时因此去世。但这个故事的转折——人们可能想知道我们为什么要谈论这个相当默默无闻的美式足球运动员——这个转折，正如我确信我们所有的美国听众肯定都知道的那样，实际上那不是乔治·吉普，那是罗纳德·里根在扮演乔治·吉普，对吧？那段是原始镜头吗，
tom that was the uh yes it was that was from the film knut rockne all american 1940 that absolutely wasn't you no it wasn't me well you could probably tell it was me because obviously it was Reagan. I mean, it's a brilliant impression, but it was Reagan as he sounded in the 1980s. The problem is whenever I think of Reagan, I think of Reagan as president because he was the first American president that I became familiar with. And we punctuate, not just Americans, all of us punctuate our lives with the American presidents who were in the background on the news in the newspapers and reagan was the first for me the gipper yeah gipper yeah people called him the gipper i mean people called him throughout his his political career people called him the gipper
汤姆？那是个，呃，是的，是的，那是1940年电影《纳特·洛克尼：全美队员》里的。那绝对不是你，不，那不是我。好吧，你大概能听出那是我就因为显然那是里根。我的意思是，这是一个精彩的模仿，但那是里根在20世纪80年代听起来的样子。问题是，每当我想起里根，我就会想起作为总统的里根，因为他是让我熟悉的第一个美国总统。我们用背景中出现在新闻和报纸上的美国总统来标点我们的生活，不仅是美国人，我们所有人都是这样，里根对我和吉普——吉普——人们称他为吉普——我是说，人们在他的整个政治生涯中都叫他吉普，
because because before he became president long long before he became president he was a a movie star yes and before he became a movie star he played a And before he became a movie star, he played a lot of sports. Yeah, he did. Well, he didn't just... And he was a kind of TV commentator. He was a radio commentator. He was a radio commentator. Yeah.
因为——因为在他成为总统之前，很久很久在他成为总统之前，他是一个电影明星，是的，在他成为电影明星之前，他扮演了一个角色——在他成为电影明星之前，他从事过很多体育运动。是的，他确实如此。嗯，他不仅……而且他算是一个电视评论员。他是一个广播评论员。他是一个广播评论员。是的。
Yes, and an extremely successful one. Yes, hello, everybody. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We are embarking on an epic journey through the life of Ronald Reagan. So our last epic journey, Tom, was through the career of Christopher Columbus. So now another great American. Another great American, exactly. So Reagan has a really extraordinary life, doesn't he?
是的，而且是一位极其成功的广播评论员。是的，大家好。欢迎收听《历史的 rest》。我们将踏上一段关于罗纳德·里根一生的史诗般的旅程。所以我们上一段史诗般的旅程，汤姆，是关于克里斯托夫·哥伦布的职业生涯。所以现在是另一位伟大的美国人。另一位伟大的美国人，没错。所以里根有着真正非凡的一生，不是吗？
I mean, it allows us to talk about so many different things. So growing up in the Midwest, the world of the early days of radio, Hollywood, the Red Scares of the late 1940s, and then obviously going into politics in California, the big governor of California, and then the tumult of the 70s, the rise of kind of populist conservatism. And then those sort of two terms. And Reagan, I suppose i suppose has i mean even i know you're not a specialist in american history tom but um reagan feels like a really consequential world figure doesn't he in a way that most american presidents arguably don't well he's got an airport named after him hasn't he yeah reagan national in washington uh and that's absolutely a measure
我的意思是，这让我们能够谈论如此多不同的事情。所以在中西部长大，早期广播的世界，好莱坞，20世纪40年代末的红色恐慌，然后显然进入加利福尼亚的政治，加州的大州长，接着是70年代的动荡，那种民粹主义保守主义的崛起。然后是那两届任期。而且里根，我想——我想——我的意思是，即使我知道你不是美国历史专家，汤姆，但是，呃，里根感觉像是一个真正具有重大影响的世界人物，不是吗？以大多数美国总统可以说是没有的方式。嗯，他有一座以他名字命名的机场，不是吗？是的，华盛顿的里根国家机场，呃，这绝对是一个衡量标准。
i get or no i suppose it isn't because for Ford's got one and all kinds of people have. But it's a big one. It's a big one, yeah. It's not the Jimmy Carter peanut facility, is it? I mean, no, and it's not just that. I mean, that sounds a bit like we're sort of being completely frivolous about it. But Reagan is also an ideological lodestar. So he's one of those figures that Republicans always invoke. I mean, rather like how British conservatives always lay claim to the mantle of Winston Churchill or
我懂，或者不，我想不是，因为福特也有一个，各种各样的人都有。但这是一个很大的机场。这是一个大机场，是的。这不是吉米·卡特的花生设施，对吧？我的意思是，不，不仅如此。我的意思是，这听起来有点像我们在对此完全轻浮。但里根也是一个意识形态的北极星。所以他是那种共和党人总是援引的人物。我的意思是，有点像英国保守党人总是宣称继承了温斯顿·丘吉尔的衣钵，或者
Margaret Thatcher. Reagan fulfills that role in a way that, you know, among modern presidents, I suppose only Franklin Roosevelt and John F. Kennedy, they do for the Democrats. But Reagan stands alone really for the Republicans, Maybe Abraham Lincoln, I suppose. My sense growing up in a Europe that was haunted by the shadow of nuclear war, my sense of Reagan growing up was a very negative one, that he was a warmonger, that he was a dangerous cowboy. You remember Spitting Image, which was a satirical British TV show involving latex puppets. And there was a kind of running gag about Reagan that he would, you know, he'd be looking for the button to press. Oh dear, I've pressed the wrong one.
玛格丽特·柴尔德。里根扮演了那个角色，你知道的，在现代总统中，我想只有富兰克林·罗斯福和约翰·F·肯尼迪为民主党人这样做。但里根对共和党人来说真的独树一帜，也许亚伯拉罕·林肯，我想。我在一个被核战争阴影笼罩的欧洲长大，我对里根的成长印象非常负面，认为他是个好战分子，是个危险的牛仔。你还记得《Spitting Image》（吐痰形象），这是一个涉及乳胶木偶的英国讽刺电视节目。当时有一个关于里根的连续笑话，他会，你知道的，他会寻找要按的按钮。“哦天哪，我按错一个了。”
There goes Moscow. Yeah. And that was a kind of running gag that he just had to press the wrong button and third world war would break out. And then suddenly he was kind of meeting up with Gorbachev in Geneva and Reykjavik and kind of even going to Moscow.achev in Geneva and Reykjavik and kind of even going to Moscow. And the Cold War seemed to be over.
莫斯科没了。是的。那是一个连续的笑话，认为他只要按错一个按钮，第三次世界大战就会爆发。然后突然间他开始在日内瓦和雷克雅未克与戈尔巴乔夫会面，甚至还去了莫斯科。……在日内瓦和雷克雅未克与戈尔巴乔夫会面，甚至还去了莫斯科。而冷战似乎已经结束了。
So there was that kind of tension, I think, in the memory that he was a cowboy who was out to shoot the bad guys and precipitate the Third World War. He was a man of peace who wanted to get rid of all nuclear weapons. So there's that ambivalence, I think, which is probably the overriding sense of ambivalence for people outside America. My sense of Reagan as a president within America is that he was a kind of a pretty terrible president in terms of his policy, but that in his role as a kind of constitutional monarch, which is also a very important part of the president's role. He was superb. And even people who were very ideologically opposed to him, who hated a lot of what his
所以记忆中存在那种紧张感，即他是一个想要射杀坏人并引发第三次世界大战的牛仔。他是一个想要消除所有核武器的和平主义者。因此，我认为存在这种矛盾心理，这可能是美国以外的人对他的普遍矛盾心理。我对里根作为美国总统的看法是，就他的政策而言，他是一个相当糟糕的总统，但在他作为一种宪法君主的角色上——这也是总统角色的一个非常重要的部分——他非常出色。即使是那些在意识形态上与他截然相反、痛恨他的很多
policies embodied, they liked him. He was a genial man. He was at moments of extreme stress in American life. Think particularly of the loss of the space shuttle when it blew up. The Challenger. The Challenger. He was superb at channeling American grief and pride and all the complexities of it. But maybe I'm being a kind of, that's my kind of sneery European perspective. That does absolutely capture how a lot of Europeans think about Reagan. I think the difference, interesting for me as somebody who writes a lot about Britain in the same period, the interesting contrast, obviously, is with Margaret Thatcher,
政策所体现的人，也喜欢他。他是一个随和的人。在生活极度紧张的时刻，想想特别是航天飞机失事爆炸的时候。“挑战者号”。“挑战者号”。他在引导美国人的悲伤和骄傲以及其中所有的复杂性方面表现得极其出色。但也许我表现得像个冷嘲热讽的欧洲人。这绝对捕捉到了许多欧洲人对里根的看法。我认为不同之处在于，对于我这样一个经常撰写同一时期英国历史的人来说，有趣的反差显然是与玛格丽特·撒切尔，
supposedly his great partner and soulmate, because they're very different, I would say, in temperament, in style, in tone. I mean, Mrs. Thatcher's so abrasive and so confrontational. Nobody loved Mrs. Thatcher.
据称是他的伟大伙伴和灵魂伴侣，因为他们非常不同，我想说，在气质、风格、基调上。我的意思是，撒切尔夫人是如此具有攻击性，如此好斗。没有人喜欢撒切尔夫人。
I mean, a few did, perhaps. If you were a very hardcore Tory, you would love Mrs. Thatcher. But she was uncompromising in her zeal for conflict and confrontation. I mean, she loved it. One of the things that emerges when you sort of study Reagan, the people around him say, the one thing about Ronald Reagan is he hated confrontation. Unless it was with the Soviets.
我的意思是，也许有少数人喜欢。如果你是一个非常强硬的托利党人，你会喜欢撒切尔夫人。但她对冲突和对抗的热情是毫不妥协的。我的意思是，她热爱这个。当你研究里根时，浮现出的事情之一是，他周围的人说，关于罗纳德·里根的一件事是，他讨厌对抗。除非是对苏联。
Yeah, and did all that he could. Well, even with the Soviets, you see, the interesting thing is that Reagan is writing in his diary how he'd love to get in a room together with the general secretary and convince him that we mean them no harm and all this kind of thing. I mean, there is this sort of, that emollience is not just a performance. I mean, well, this is a thing we'll discuss. With Reagan, it is, of course, always a performance. He is the politician as performer par excellence. But the key to Reagan, it seems to me, is that he absolutely believes in his own performance. And to some degree,
是的，并且竭尽所能。好吧，即使是对苏联，你看，有趣的是，里根在他的日记中写到他多么想和总书记共处一室，让他们确信我们对他们没有恶意以及诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，有这样一种，这种温和不仅仅是一场表演。我的意思是，这是我们将要讨论的事情。对于里根来说，这当然永远是一场表演。他是登峰造极的表演型政治家。但里根的关键，在我看来，是他绝对相信自己的表演。并在某种程度上，
I mean, one of the interesting things about him when he's a film star is people always say, he's at his best when he's playing himself i mean this the sort of mirrors within mirrors you know he has this fantasy image of what a president should be or what an american should be and he's absolutely determined to play it but he's he's never really aware that it's a performance is he he never lets you in on the it's not like boris johnson who's always winking and joking and drawing attention to the artifice. Reagan does an absolute sincerity to his portrayal of himself as the president. embodies so much that defined America in the 20th century to a startling degree. So in his memoirs, he talks about growing up with white picket fences, even though as we'll find out, his upbringing was much more darker than that, really. He plays sports at high school. He does the high school romance. He goes to college. He is a lifeguard. He becomes a
我的意思是，关于他的一件有趣的事情是，当他是个电影明星时，人们总是说，他在扮演自己时表现最好——我的意思是，这种镜中之镜——你知道，他对自己应该成为一个什么样的总统或一个什么样的美国人有着这种幻想的形象，并且他绝对决心去扮演它。但他从未真正意识到这是一场表演，不是吗？他从未让你窥见内情。他不像鲍里斯·约翰逊那样总是眨眼、开玩笑并吸引人们注意其虚伪。里根对把自己塑造成总统有着绝对的真诚。在惊人的程度上，他体现了那么多定义了20世纪美国的东西。因此，在他的回忆录中，他谈到了伴随着白色尖桩篱栅长大，尽管正如我们将要发现的，他的成长经历实际上要黑暗得多。他在高中做运动。他经历高中的浪漫。他上大学。他是个救生员。他成了
Hollywood actor. It's astonishing the degree to which he has within himself all these kind of ideals, these visions, these fantasies, these dreams that Americans have always had about themselves and the way that that has served to define America in the eyes of the world. And he draws on all of that as a politician, superbly. But the question then is, which we've already fencing around, to what extent is it performative and to what extent is he what he seems to be? Well, it's a fascinating question, isn't it? With politicians, you could argue that everything is always performative, but that's the point. That's not inauthentic. Henry Kissinger in 1971, pretty shallow. And then that's the charge throughout his presidency, is that basically he's a kind of a mannequin or he's an actor speaking lines
好莱坞演员。令人惊讶的是，他内心深处拥有所有这些理想、愿景、幻想、梦想——美国人一直以来对他们自己的看法，以及这如何在世人眼中定义了美国。作为一名政治家，他出色地汲取了所有这些。但随后问题来了，这也是我们一直在讨论的，这在多大程度上是表演性质的，在多大程度上他就是他看起来的那样？嗯，这是一个迷人的问题，不是吗？对于政治家，你可以争辩说一切永远都是表演性质的，但关键就在于此。这并非不真实。1971年的亨利·基辛格，相当肤浅。然后这就是他整个总统任期内受到的指控，即他基本上是一个人体模特或一个台词演员，
and that people have to give him the scripts. And the question as to whether there is actually any depth beneath that seeming shallowness is kind of interesting. That's a fascinating one. And just as a spoiler, I don't think he is shallow. I think, I mean, the interesting thing about Reagan,, the thing about the scripts, he writes those scripts. He absolutely believes, and as we'll come to in this episode, in Hollywood, he was notorious for being, you wouldn't want to sit next to him at lunch because he would just bore you about world affairs and politics but which he probably picked up from reader's digest well that's true he picks up the reader's digest yeah you're absolutely right anyway so let's talk a little bit about uh about reagan's background because this actually is a really interesting story isn't it tom
人们不得不给他剧本。而关于那种看似肤浅的表象下是否真的存在任何深度的讨论是相当有趣的。这是一个引人入胜的问题。作为一个剧透，我不认为他是肤浅的。我认为——我的意思是，关于里根有趣的一点，关于剧本的事，他自己写那些剧本。他绝对相信——正如我们将在本集里谈到的——在好莱坞，他以……你不会想在午餐时坐在他旁边，因为他会一直对你唠叨世界事务和政治——而这些他可能是从《读者文摘》里看来的。好吧，那是真的，他看《读者文摘》，是的，你完全说得对。无论如何，让我们来谈谈里根的背景，因为这实际上是一个非常有趣的故事，不是吗，汤姆？
that's fascinating so he's born in 1911 um tampico illinois uh which one of his biographers i think it's bob spitz describes tampico as says it's basically like the set of a low budget Western. So he's in the Midwest. Right. And the whole way through his life, both the settings and the people around him are like people from films. Yeah, they are.
这太迷人了，所以他生于1911年，伊利诺伊州坦皮科——他的传记作家之一，我想是鲍勃·斯皮茨，把坦皮科描述为基本上就像一部低成本西部片的布景。所以他在中西部。没错。在他的一生中，他的环境和周围的人都像是电影里的人。是的，他们确实如此。
Even his parents are actually to some degree, aren't they? They are rather stereotypical. Jack, Jack Reagan and Nellie Wilson. Well, or even before that, I mean, so they come from Irelandireland yeah via london by peckham interestingly um and they they go they you know they become prospectors so it's a little house on the prairie all that kind of stuff um his great uncles go
甚至他的父母在某种程度上也是如此，不是吗？他们相当刻板。杰克、杰克·里根和内莉·威尔逊。好吧，甚至在此之前，我的意思是，他们来自爱尔兰——爱尔兰，是的，经由伦敦，有趣的是经由佩卡姆——他们去，他们去，他们成为了勘探者，所以就像《草原小屋》所有那些东西——他的曾叔祖父们去
gold prospecting um and two of them end up being eaten because they get stuck in a snowstorm. Who eats them? The other prospectors. That's bad form, isn't it? I'd hope for better from my prospecting comrades. But the idea of Reagan as a cowboy, I mean, his great uncles died in the Wild West at its wildest. Yeah. So that is all part of the background. The funny thing is, even though he sort of dressed up as a cowboy on his ranch, he was always very cross when people called him a cowboy.
淘金——其中两个人最终被吃掉了，因为他们被困在了暴风雪中。谁吃掉了他们？其他勘探者。这真是不体面，不是吗？我本希望我的勘探同志们表现得更好。但里根作为牛仔的想法——我的意思是，他的曾叔祖父们死于最狂野的狂野西部。所以这都是背景的一部分。有趣的是，尽管他在牧场上把自己打扮成一个牛仔，但每当别人叫他牛仔时，他总是非常生气。
And he said, I didn't do many Westerns. He did about seven Westerns or something. But that's a sign of that American iconography, how quickly people associated the two. And he himself, there are loads of photos of him in a denim shirt, kind of on his ranch with a horse. So he grows up in the Midwest. Don't you think that a huge part of his appeal is that he embodies an ideal of America that is associated with the Midwest? Yeah.
他说：“我没演过多少西部片。”他大约演了七部西部片左右。但这标志着美国的偶像崇拜，人们把这两者联系起来的速度有多快。他自己也有很多穿着牛仔衬衫、在牧场里骑马的照片。所以他在中西部长大。你不认为他吸引力的很大一部分在于他体现了一种与中西部有关的美国理想吗？是的。
It's kind of, it's virtues, it's hardiness, it's provincialism. Absolutely. Absolutely. Couldn't agree more. I think he has a fantasy of America himself. He has, at the core of Reagan is an idea of America, I think, that he completely and utterly believes in. And it's a very Midwestern idea. It's not the world of the coasts. It's not urban or metropolitan. It's not especially diverse or multicultural. Well, not at all, is it? I guess we'll talk about Reagan and race a little bit later, but there are not many African-Americans in Reagan's early years. It's a world of small towns. If you've ever been, for our British listeners, if you've ever been to some of these places, to Illinois, to Iowa, to Minnesota, I mean, I lived for a year in Minnesota, you are a long way, you're an awful long way from anywhere. And there are these small towns with an enormous sense of civic pride, the kind of thing actually that in Britain we don't have at all and we automatically scoff at, where people make their own,
这是一种，它的美德，它的坚韧，它的狭隘。绝对的。绝对的。完全同意。我认为他自己对美国有一种幻想。里根的核心是一种关于美国的想法，我认为他完全且彻底地相信。这是一个非常中中西部的想法。这不是沿海世界。这不是城市或大都市。它不是特别多元化或多元文化。嗯，一点也不，不是吗？我想我们稍后会讨论里根与种族的问题，但在里根的早期，没有多少非裔美国人。这是一个小镇的世界。如果你去过，对我们的英国听众来说，如果你去过其中一些地方，去过伊利诺伊州，爱荷华州，明尼苏达州——我的意思是，我在明尼苏达州住过一年——你离得很远，离任何地方都远得可怕。那里有这样的小镇，有着巨大的公民自豪感，这种东西实际上在英国根本没有，而我们也会自动嘲笑它，在那里人们自己制造，
they don't just make their own entertainment, but they make their own civic culture. Yeah, so Reagan's mother, for example, Nellie, we'll talk a bit more about her in a second, but she is absolutely one of these people who throws herself into the local community in a completely unironic way. You know, I'm going to join the church. I'm going to join the amateur dramatic society. I'm going to do loads of charitable things. And that sort of small town world where everybody knows everybody else, you know, that fantasy, if you like, Reagan as a little boy completely imbibes that. And it would never occur to him to question it or to mock it
他们不仅自己制造娱乐，还自己制造公民文化。是的，所以里根的母亲，例如，内莉，我们一会儿会多谈谈她，但她绝对是那种完全不带讽刺意味地投入到当地社区的人。你知道，我要加入教堂。我要加入业余戏剧协会。我要做大量的慈善活动。那种小镇世界，每个人都认识其他人，你知道，这种幻想，如果你愿意的话，小童年时代的里根完全吸收了这一点。而且他绝不会想到去质疑它或嘲笑它，
or to do all these things, which as Europeans, we automatically do. And in his memories of it, it's the embodiment of all these tales of, I suppose, kind of Mark Twain going back to all that, the idea of, so he writes about there were woods and mysteries, life and death among small creatures, hunting and fishing, that kind of idea that this is a paradise for a child. And that idea that a paradise has been lost is often there in conservatives. I mean, it's kind of a wellspring for conservatism in adult life. But the thing that's fascinating about Reagan is that it's not just white picket fences, because there is also quite a lot of darkness.
或者做所有这些作为欧洲人我们自然而然会做的事情。在他对此的回忆中，它是所有这些故事的化身，我想，有点像马克·吐温追溯到这一切，那种想法——所以他写道，那里有树林和神秘，小动物之间的生与死，打猎和钓鱼，那种想法认为这对孩子来说是天堂。而这种天堂已经失落的想法在保守派中经常存在。我的意思是，这可以说是成年生活中保守主义的源泉。但关于里根迷人的一点是，这不仅仅是白色尖桩篱栅，因为其中也有相当多的黑暗。
Yeah. So his father, Jack, he's from Fulton, Illinois. As you said, sort of irish background uh he's a shoe salesman which sounds kind of banal but actually at the time in the sort of 1910s 1920s the department store was king and to be a salesman in the department store was was a kind of i mean i don't want to oversell it's not a massive deal massive deal, but it's not nothing. Bob Spitz in his biography of Reagan has the great phrase, he developed a flair for fitting the female foot. What a thing to have as your avatar.
是的。所以他的父亲杰克，他来自伊利诺伊州富尔顿。正如你所说，有点爱尔兰背景，呃，他是一名鞋类推销员，这听起来有点平庸，但实际上在20世纪10年代、20年代左右，百货公司才是王道，而百货公司的推销员是一种——我的意思是，我不想过分夸大，这不是一件大事，不是什么了不起的大事，但也不是什么都没有。鲍勃·斯皮茨在他的里根传记中有一句绝妙的话：“他培养了一种迎合女性足部尺寸的天赋。”作为你的头像，这算是什么事啊。
He's tall, he's charming, he's gregarious. He's very political, actually. So the idea that Reagan, I mean, this obviously hangs over Reagan all his career, the idea that he's merely a puppet or a front man. He comes from quite a political family. And the politics is Democrat. Yeah. Politics is Democrat.
他很高，很有魅力，很合群。实际上非常热心政治。所以里根的观点——这显然一直悬在里根的整个职业生涯中——他仅仅是一个木偶或傀儡的观点。他来自一个相当有政治色彩的家庭。而且政治倾向是民主党。是的。政治倾向是民主党。
Very interested in social causes, social issues, minimum wage, welfare, all that sort of stuff. I mean, as an Irishman, he's almost automatically going to be a Democrat anyway, because politics in the late 19th, early 20th century is very sort of sectarian but um yeah he's he talks about this at the dinner table the cloud of course is is drink so so jack is yeah there's some questions about whether he's an alcoholic or a binge drinker i mean as if you can sort of separate the two he's definitely i mean he's definitely a binge drinker and he drinks a lot. And this, I mean, this is clearly an issue
对社会事业、社会问题、最低工资、福利等所有这些东西都很感兴趣。我的意思是，作为一个爱尔兰人，他几乎自动就会成为民主党人，因为19世纪末、20世纪初的政治具有非常强烈的宗派色彩，但是——是的，他在餐桌上谈论这些，当然，阴云是酒——所以杰克是——有些关于他是否是酒鬼或狂饮者的疑问——就好像你能把这两者分开一样——他绝对是——我的意思是，他绝对是个狂饮者，他喝很多酒。这意味着，这显然是一个问题，
for the family and for, and for young, well, Dutch, as he's called. He's not called Ronald, is he?
对家庭，对——对年轻的——嗯，小名“荷兰人”（Dutch），因为他当时叫这个。他不叫罗纳德，不是吗？
Nobody calls him Ronald at this point. Everyone calls him Dutch. Dutch after his hairstyle, a Dutch Bob. A Dutch Bob. Yeah. But the,
此时没有人叫他罗纳德。每个人都叫他荷兰人。因为他的发型叫“荷兰式波波头”（Dutch Bob），所以叫荷兰人。一个荷兰式波波头。是的。但是，
I mean, the salient fact about Jack Reagan and, and his drinking is that it affects his ability to work. And so they keep having to move town and their lodgings become kind of poorer and poorer and poorer. So there's a sense of a downward spiral, even as Dutch is loving life. He's clearly a person with a great appetite for life. But Jack never loses his principles. And Reagan remembers, he refuses to let his... Ronald Reagan has an elder brother who goes by the nickname of Moon. What's he called? Neil, I think.
我的意思是，关于杰克·里根及其饮酒的显著事实是，这影响了他的工作能力。所以他们不得不不断搬家，他们的住处变得越来越破烂。所以有一种螺旋式下降的感觉，尽管荷兰人热爱生活。他显然是一个对生活有着巨大胃口的人。但杰克从未失去他的原则。里根记得，他拒绝让他的……罗纳德·里根有一个哥哥，绰号叫“月亮”（Moon）。他叫什么名字？尼尔，我想。
Neil. I'd choose Moon over Neil, frankly. I mean, no offense to any Neil listeners um and but moon listeners will be delighted by that remark um so moon and Dutch are not allowed to watch um birth of a nation the very racist film when it comes out and Reagan owns there was no more greed of a sin at our household than a racial slur or other evidence of religious or racial intolerance Tom your role Reagan is very very good. You were reluctant to do it before we started recording, and I really had to twist your arm and sort of shout at you to get you to do it.
尼尔。坦率地说，比起尼尔，我更愿意选月亮。我的意思是，无意冒犯任何叫尼尔的听众，并且——月亮听众会对这个评论感到高兴的——所以月亮和荷兰人不允许观看——《一个国家的诞生》，那部当它上映时非常种族的电影，里根承认：在我们家里，没有任何罪过比种族侮辱或宗教或种族不容忍的其他证据更贪婪的了。汤姆，你扮演的罗纳德·里根非常非常棒。在我们开始录音之前，你很不情愿这么做，我真的不得不扭你的胳膊，对你大喊大叫才让你这么做的。
But I'm glad Ronald Reagan is joining us for this podcast. So that I found really interesting reading up about Reagan's childhood, was the omnipresent sense that Jack Reagan embodies a very kind of principled devotion to FDR, New Deal, all that kind of stuff, that he's very opposed to anything that smacks of racial prejudice, religious prejudice. And on that topic, of course, it's interesting that he has actually married, he's a Catholic, he's married a Protestant. And that's very unusual, isn't it? It is unusual. And Nellie is not, I mean, she's not just somebody from a Protestant background. So Jack is kind of, you know, the big man, kind of tall and gregarious and stuff. And Nellie is more innocent, I suppose, and deeply, deeply religious. I mean,
但我很高兴罗纳德·里根能加入我们的这个播客。所以我发现在阅读里根的童年经历时非常有趣的是那种无所不在的感觉：杰克·里根体现了一种非常原则性的奉献精神，忠于富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）、新政以及所有这些东西，他非常反对任何带有种族偏见、宗教偏见色彩的东西。而在这个话题上，当然有趣的是，他实际上已经结婚了，他是个天主教徒，他娶了一个新教徒。这非常不寻常，不是吗？确实不寻常。而内莉不是——我的意思是，她不仅仅是一个来自新教背景的人。所以杰克有点像那种——大男人，身材高大，合群之类的。而内莉则更单纯，我想，而且非常非常宗教。我的意思是，
so she joins a group called the Disciples of, a church called the Disciples of Christ, 1910. By the standards of sort of evangelicalist churches, they are quite, they're very kind of moderate, aren't they? I mean, they're just- But passionately committed. Yeah. To good works. They sound very attractive as sort of brands go, Christian brands go.
所以她加入了一个名为“基督门徒”的团体，一个名为“基督门徒”的教会，1910年。按照某种福音派教会的标准，他们相当，他们是非常温和的，不是吗？我的意思是，他们只是——但充满激情地投入。是的。致力于慈善事业。作为一个品牌来说，基督教品牌听起来非常有吸引力。
They're a very appealing one, aren't they? They're devoted to the social gospel. The aim is that you do a charitable deed every day which she does yeah um she and she really throws herself into a part of the because jack is off boozing and and fitting shoes to the female the female foot so she is and she goes on the road for the disciples of christ And she does recitals and she does talks and she reads Christian poetry and all of that, undoubtedly. I had not appreciated until really digging into Reagan's background. I always thought his talk of God was skin deep and it's patently obvious that it isn't. And he feels it very young because it's a church where you have full immersive baptism, but you have to choose to be baptised.
这是一个非常吸引人的品牌，不是吗？他们致力于社会福音。目标是每天做一件慈善好事——她确实这么做了。是的，呃——她真正全身心投入到其中一部分中，因为杰克一直在酗酒，并为女性的足部——女性的足部试鞋，所以她一直在——她为基督门徒四处奔波。她做朗诵，做演讲，朗诵基督教诗歌，毫无疑问，所有这些。在真正深入研究里根的背景之前，我并没有意识到这一点。我一直认为他对上帝的谈话只是流于表面，但显而易见并非如此。他在很小的时候就感受到了这一点，因为那是一个进行完全沉浸式洗礼的教会，但你必须选择接受洗礼。
And both Dutch and Moon want to have it done very young. They do. And she agrees. And he always holds to it. Well, he reads a book, which is a sort of Disciples of Christ fictional bestseller called That Printer of Oudels by Harold Bell Wright. And the hero of that is called Dick Faulkner. And at one point, he comes across his own father, who's an alcoholic, passed out, drunk. And this obviously made a big impression on Reagan because he has a story.
荷兰人和月亮都想在很小的时候就完成这个。他们确实这么做了。她也同意了。而且他一直坚守这一点。好吧，他读了一本书，这是一本“基督门徒”虚构的畅销书，名叫《奥德尔的那个打印机》（That Printer of Oudels），作者是哈罗德·贝尔·赖特（Harold Bell Wright）。其中的英雄名叫迪克·福克纳（Dick Faulkner）。有一次，他遇到了自己的父亲，一个酒鬼，喝得不省人事。这显然给里根留下了深刻的印象，因为他有一个故事。
It's always hard to tell with Reagan, of course, where his own recollections begin and fiction ends. But he has a story about doing that with his own father. And clearly this book, that printer, had a massive effect on him because when he was 11, he went to his mother and said, please have me baptized in the disciples of Christ. And again, as Europeans, I think in the 1980s, we sort of thought, oh, ha ha, this is all just completely fake and inauthentic and sort of pandering to his constituency. Not a bit of it. He genuinely,
当然，对于里根来说，很难判断他自己的回忆从哪里开始，虚构从哪里结束。但他有一个关于对自己的父亲做这件事的故事。显然这本书，那个打印机，对他产生了巨大的影响，因为当他11岁时，他走到母亲面前说，请让我接受基督门徒的洗礼。同样，作为欧洲人，我认为在20世纪80年代，我们某种程度上认为，哦，哈哈，这完全是虚假的、不真实的，只是在迎合他的选民。一点也不是。他真诚地，
all his life, he takes this stuff enormously seriously, that faith element. So the combination of kind of Jack, charming, real hit with the ladies, a man's man, I suppose you would say, a man who will have a glass of whiskey with you and tell you a kind of funny story. And then Nellie, really interested in sort of, you know, she's a performer, but she loves taking the stage and talking to people about good and evil,
一生都在极其严肃地对待这些东西，也就是信仰的元素。所以，杰克那种富有魅力、深受女士欢迎、可以说是男人的男人的组合——一个会和你喝一杯威士忌并给你讲个有趣故事的人。然后是内莉，真正对那种——你知道的，她是一个表演者，但她喜欢走上舞台，和人们谈论善恶，
right and wrong, you know, the path of Christ. I mean, you can see them in Ronald, can't you? And that, again, is the stereotype of Reagan in 80s Europe, is that he's a person who sees the world in Manichaean terms, who sees it in terms of good and evil. And this is something that I think isn't entirely wrong. I think Reagan is very, very prone to seeing the world in terms of of good and evil yeah and one of the obviously the um his his mother's church is a huge example influence on that but another one is his early love of movies and this is a period where you can tell who the goody is because he's wearing a white hat yeah and you can tell who the baddies
对与错，你知道的，基督的道路。我的意思是，你能在罗纳德身上看到他们的影子，不是吗？而这，再次成为80年代欧洲对里根的刻板印象，即他是一个以摩尼教二元论观点看待世界的人，以善恶二元论来看待世界的人。而这我认为并非完全错误。我认为里根非常非常倾向于用善恶二元论来审视世界——是的——而显然其中一个，呃，他的母亲的教会是一个巨大的例子，对这一点产生了影响，但另一个则是他早期对电影的热爱。这是一个你可以通过看谁戴着白帽子来辨别谁是好人的时期，
are because they're wearing black hats and am I unfair in saying that that essentially establishes his understanding of how the world is? I don't think you are unfair. I think he definitely has a strong sense that the world is a, you know, his antipathy to communism later in his life, you know, that is shot through with a very clear sense of there is good and evil. When he talks about the evil empire, the Soviet Union is the focus for evil in the modern world, as he does in 1983, that's not just a speechwriter talking, that's reflecting his deep sense, which actually he definitely shares with Margaret Thatcher, who also comes from, by British standards, an unusually God-fearing, low church, Methodist background. They bond over that because when they're meeting with other kind of world-weary, you know, Helmut Schmidt, Helmut Kohl, these kinds of people, they probably don't go,
是的，你可以通过看谁戴着黑帽子来辨别谁是坏人——我说他基本上确立了他对世界运作方式的理解，这公平吗？我不认为你不公平。我认为他绝对有一种强烈的感觉，即世界是一个——你知道的，他后来对共产主义的反感，你知道的，这其中贯穿了一种非常清晰的善恶观念。当他在1983年谈到“邪恶帝国”时，苏联是现代世界邪恶的焦点，那不仅仅是一个演讲撰稿人在说话，那反映了他内心深处的感受——这实际上他绝对与玛格丽特·撒切尔有共鸣，玛格丽特·撒切尔也来自一个英国标准下不同寻常的、敬畏上帝的、低教会派的卫理公会背景。他们因为这一点而建立了联系，因为当他们与其他某种世界厌倦的——你知道的，赫尔穆特·施密特、赫尔穆特·科尔这样的人会面时，他们可能不会去——
Mitterrand, they probably don't go in for this kind of stuff. Their moralism marks them out. And I think a lot of people actually, for both, it's true, both Reagan and Thatcher, but even more so for Reagan, I think his moralism and his Manichaeanism in the 1970s, a very confused sort of post-Vietnam period, a lot of people found that actually really invigorating to have somebody who stands up and says there's good and evil. But I think also what people responded to later in Reagan's later career is the sense that he had really walked the American walk. Yeah.
密特朗，他们可能不会涉足这种东西。他们的道德主义使他们显得与众不同。我认为实际上很多人，对里根和撒切尔两人来说都是如此，但对里根而言更是如此，我认为他在20世纪70年代——一个非常混乱的后越战时期——的道德主义和摩尼教二元论，让许多人觉得实际上真的令人振奋，能有一个挺身而出说存在善恶的人。但我认为人们在里根后来的职业生涯中做出回应的还有那种他真正走过美国之路的感觉。是的。
That he has the high school sweetheart, who's a girl called Margaret Cleaver. Mugs. Mugs. What a great name. He plays sport. The basketball team he plays for is brilliantly called the Whiffle Puffs. Yeah. Are they basketball or baseball?
他有青梅竹马的高中恋人，一个叫玛格丽特·克利弗的女孩。“马格斯”（Mugs）。多么棒的名字。他从事体育运动。他效力过的篮球队有个绝妙的名字叫“惠夫泡芙”（Whiffle Puffs）。是的。他们是打篮球还是棒球？
Basketball. Basketball. So he's playing basketball. He plays baseball. But football is his passion. Football is the sport he reallyica which he will then go on to play the gipper yeah of course and he makes he makes his money by being a serving as a lifeguard a lifeguard yeah and that sense of kind of strapping health high school all that you know everything that but not just americans think about when they think of small-town America. Reagan is living that life.
篮球。篮球。所以他在打篮球。他打棒球。但美式足球是他的激情所在。美式足球是他真正热爱的运动，他后来将去扮演吉普——是的，当然。他通过担任救生员来赚钱——救生员，是的。那种健康的体魄、高中生活、所有这些，你知道，不仅是美国人在想到小镇美国时想到的所有事情。里根正在过着那样的生活。
And ironically, in a kind of, you know, he loves it. Yeah. So people say about him when he's a teenager, people admire him, people like him. Nobody really knows him, even then. I mean, all through his career, people say, you don't know Ronald Reagan. He doesn't share his feelings. He doesn't have, for example, close male friends. Everybody likes him, but he doesn't have a soulmate.
而且具有讽刺意味的是，在某种程度上——你知道的，他很喜欢它。是的。所以当他是个十几岁的时候，人们这样评价他：人们钦佩他，人们喜欢他。即使在那个时候，也没有人真正了解他。我的意思是，在他整个职业生涯中，人们都说，你不了解罗纳德·里根。他不分享自己的感受。例如，他没有亲密的男性朋友。每个人都喜欢他，但他没有灵魂伴侣。
I mean, obviously, there's mugs. He loves acting, even as a teenager. He's into the church. I mean, his mother, it's interesting. His parents are kind of, it's later said of him that he makes guest appearances with his own family and his own children because he's always off doing something else. And that's true of his parents too, isn't it? Because by the time he's a teenager, his mother is at church, his father is in the pub or something.
我的意思是，显然有马格斯。他喜欢表演，甚至在十几岁的时候就是这样。他热衷于教会。我的意思是，他的母亲，这很有趣。他的父母有点——后来有人说他跟自己的家庭和孩子在一起时就像是客串出场，因为他总是忙着做别的事。对他的父母来说也是如此，不是吗？因为当他是十几岁的时候，他母亲在教堂，他父亲在酒吧什么的。
And yet, a bit like when we did our podcast about the young Churchill, it's an interesting lesson in the power of temperament because Reagan could so easily have been bitter, that his parents were never there they were never there his father was drinking that their circumstances were so straightened but he has this incredible optimism sunniness sun so his high school yearbook you write your own motto in your high school yearbook and his motto is life is one sweet song so start the music and for it is inconceivable that a british teenager would ever listen to the smiths yeah would ever write those words i mean it's just at no stage i
然而，有点像我们制作关于年轻丘吉尔的播客一样，这是关于性格力量的一个有趣教训，因为里根本来很容易变得痛苦——他的父母从不在身边，他们从来不在，他父亲酗酒，他们的环境如此窘迫——但他拥有这种令人难以置信的乐观主义，阳光。所以他的高中年鉴里，你在自己的高中年鉴里写下你自己的座右铭，而他的座右铭是“生活是一首美妙的歌，所以开始奏乐吧”。对于一个英国青少年来说，去听The Smiths乐队——是的——去写下那些话是不可思议的——我的意思是，这简直是——在英国历史的任何阶段，都不会有人在不笑的情况下说出这句话——但里根，你知道，这是他迷人的地方之一，也是为什么阅读关于他的经历实际上是一种乐趣的原因——因为有一个如此阳光和乐观的人是极其罕见的。是的。他去，他最终去了一所大学，不是吗？尤里卡。
think in britain's history would anybody have have said that that sentence without laughing but reagan you know it's one of the attractive things about him it's one of the reasons that actually is a pleasure to read about yeah because it's so unusual to have somebody so sunny and optimistic. Yeah. And he goes to, he ends up going to a college, doesn't he? Eureka.
是的。这真是一个绝佳的大学名字。尤里卡学院。其中同样贯穿了一种阳光感。它非常非常——我的意思是，它非常进步。
Yeah. Which is a great name for a college. Eureka College. Which again has a kind of sunniness shot through it. It's very, very by the, I mean, it's very progressive.
是的。由废奴主义者创立，“基督门徒”教会，是的。当里根去那里时，有一个——迎新日，特邀嘉宾是一位认识林肯的内战老兵。好的。是的，那种——他显然从他父亲那里得到的，以及他从马格斯那里得到的，马格斯也去了那里，而里根必须获得奖学金——我的意思是，他上不起。基本上，他们把奖学金发给每个人，因为他们就是那种机构。是的，而且他擅长体育。好吧，他挺擅长体育的。
Yes. Founded by abolitionists, disciples christ yeah and when reagan goes there's um the orientation day the guest of honor is um a civil war veteran who'd known lincoln okay yeah that sense of um that he's obviously got from his dad and that he gets from from mugs who's gone there and reagan has to get a scholarship i mean he can't afford to go. Basically, they kind of chuck out scholarships to everyone because they're that kind of institution. Yeah, and he's good at sports. Well, he's quite good at sports.
他工作非常努力，全身心投入其中。他不太擅长学术作业，不是吗？他有点得过且过，拿C和D什么的。但他在表演。他在演戏。甚至当他在美式足球队时，他也会模仿体育播音员。对。
He works really hard and throws himself into it. He's not very good at his academic work, is he? He sort of coasts, gets Cs and Ds or something. But he's acting. He's doing his acting. Even when he's on the football team, he will impersonate sportscasters. Right.
而且显然他模仿富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）非常出色。好吧，他当然热爱罗斯福。所以富兰克林·罗斯福即将——罗斯福还不是总统，但罗斯福是即将崭露头角的人物，是纽约州州长。里根家族崇拜罗斯福。里根一生都认为罗斯福是总统的绝对典范。我告诉你一件事，他在尤里卡学院养成的一个癖好——
And he also apparently has a very good impersonation of FDR. Well, he loves FDR, of course. So FDR is about to, FDR is not quite yet president, but FDR is the kind of coming man who's governor of New York. And the Reagan family adore FDR. And Reagan all his life thought FDR was the absolute model of a president. I'll tell you one thing, that an affectation he developed at Eureka College
我为他放弃抽烟斗感到遗憾。嗯，还有他放弃的另一件事，当然是戴眼镜，因为他极其近视。是的。我从来没有意识到这一点。你从没见过他戴眼镜，对吧？不，从来没有。你永远不会以总统的身份在公共场合戴眼镜。
that I'm sorry he abandoned is smoking a pipe. Well, and also the other thing that he, of course, abandons is wearing glasses because he's incredibly short-sighted. Yeah. And I'd never realised that. You never see him with glasses, do you? No, never. You would never appear in public as president.
我的意思是，就像他不会在没有衬衫领带、全套西装和靴子的公共场合以总统身份露面一样，以防他不想看起来像吉米·卡特。但这就是为什么他永远不能成为真正顶尖的运动员的原因。对。你知道的，有点像我。但是，汤姆，你戴眼镜。我们有天赋。
I mean, just like he wouldn't appear in public as president without a shirt and tie and a full suit and boots, in case he doesn't want to look like Jimmy Carter. But that's why he could never be a truly elite sportsman. Right. You know, a bit like me. But, Tommy, you wear glasses. We have the natural ability.
是的，因为我只是觉得凭我的长相，我可以驾驭它们。所以，实际上，他们的相似之处非常惊人。是的，在很多方面。因为你也是，正如人们从乔治·吉普那件事中看出的那样，你也是一个出色的、相当出色的演员，不是吗？是的，是的，是的。
Yeah, because I just think that with my looks, I can get away with them. So, actually, their parallels are quite uncanny. Yeah, you wear glasses. We have the natural ability. Yeah, because I just think that with my looks, I can get away with them. So, actually, their parallels are quite uncanny. Yeah, in many ways. Because you're also, as people will have gauged from that George Gipp business, you're also a brilliant, quite brilliant actor, aren't you? Yes, yes, yes.
好吧，这不由我来说，但非常有可能。好吧，我在推特上读了我们的听众对你模仿秀的反馈。例如，你最近做了什么？你模仿了《黑道家族》。是的。还有非凡的反馈，我认为这样说很公平。所以我本可以去好莱坞，就像里根最终做的那样，不是吗？因为他不玩体育了，所以他决定去解说体育。
Well, it's not for me to say, but very possibly. Well, I read the feedback on your impersonations on Twitter from our listeners. For example, what did you do recently? You did The Sopranos. Yeah. And extraordinary feedback, I think it's fair to say. So I could have gone to Hollywood, as Reagan ends up doing, doesn't he? Because he doesn't play sport, so he decides to commentate on it.
好吧，在我们进入他的体育解说生涯之前，我们应该休息一下，汤姆，因为那是一个非凡的故事。好的。所以我们休息后见，来听听一些体育解说。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的娱乐》。这里有你每周的娱乐新闻、评论，
Well, we should take a break, Tom, before we get into his sportscasting career, because that is a remarkable story. Okay. So we'll see you after the break for some sportscasting. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
以及少许的演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们正在谈论罗纳德·里根。汤姆，那是1932年。
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about Ronald Reagan. And Tom, it's 1932.
加点娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正在讨论罗纳德·里根。汤姆，那是1932年。
The United States is in the depths of the Great Depression one in four people are out of work but not Ronald Wilson Reagan because he he is determined to mugs his girlfriend has a dream they'll both be teachers but he's not really interested in being a teacher he likes he's already interested in the kind of showbiz world, but the world of sport. So he goes off to sports. Yes, I'm so sorry. You take the S from maths and put it onto sports, and that's how you speak American. He goes off to Chicago, tries to get his foot in the door, but doesn't manage it. But he ends up through various contacts in Davenport, Iowa, for the brilliant radio station World of Chiropractic. Aha!
美国正处于大萧条的谷底，四分之一的人失业，但罗纳德·威尔逊·里根例外，因为他，他决心去……他的女友有个梦想，他们俩会成为老师，但他其实对当老师不感兴趣，他喜欢，他对那种秀场世界、体育界已经感兴趣了。所以他转向了体育。是的，非常抱歉。你把maths里的s去掉加到sports上，这就是美式英语的说话方式。他去了芝加哥，试图踏进这一行，但没能成功。不过通过各种人脉，他最终来到了爱荷华州达文波特，进入了那家出色的广播电台“脊骨疗法世界”。啊哈！
WOC. So the guy who owns it, who's BJ Palmer, his father, invented chiropractice, apparently. And they basically give Reagan a trial, sort of off the cuff. He improvises commentary on a game that
WOC。所以拥有它的那个人，也就是BJ·帕尔默，他的父亲显然发明了脊骨疗法。他们基本上是即兴给里根安排了一场试镜。他为一场比赛即兴进行了解说……
Eureka had played against western state and they say brilliant you know they give him the job and then he goes off to des moines iowa for their sister station who and he rises to be their chief sportscaster doesn't he and he's he's he's actually brilliant and the amazing thing is he never does any of the games well he can't see any of the games. He can't see it. Well, there's a famous anecdote that he tells later about, you know, the details are coming through and then it cuts out. Yeah, for six minutes.
尤里卡对阵西区州的比赛，他们说太棒了，你知道的，他们给了他一份工作，然后他去了爱荷华州得梅因他们旗下的姊妹电台WHO，他一路晋升为他们的首席体育解说员，对吧？而且他真的，真的，真的非常出色，神奇的是他从来不做任何现场比赛解说——好吧，他根本看不到任何比赛。他看不见。好吧，有个著名的轶事，他后来讲述过，你知道，比赛细节传过来然后信号中断了。对，中断了六分钟。
And so for six minutes, he just completely makes it up. Yeah. And then when they come back on, so he's been delaying for six minutes and inventing fouls and stuff and describing the background. And then it comes back on to discover that the batter was out within seconds of the wire going down. So this is often taken by Reagan's more hostile biographers as sort of evidence of his addiction to fantasy
所以有六分钟的时间，他完全是凭空捏造的。对。然后当信号恢复时，他已经拖延了六分钟，编造了犯规之类的情节并描述了背景。接着信号恢复了，却发现击球手在电报线中断后几秒钟内就已经出局了。所以这经常被里根那些比较刻薄的传记作者当作证据，证明他沉迷于幻想……
and his sort of dishonesty and artifice. But almost all commentary like this was done this way. So basically you would get the wire telegraph wire western union and it would tell you what had happened you had the crowd noise on a on a record next to you and you described what happened and and of course the brilliant thing was it had that classic sort of as a british observer that american thing of that love of inflating things so you would just make the play as exciting and as dramatic as possible. I mean,
以及他的某种不诚实和虚伪。但几乎所有的类似评论都是这么做的。所以基本上你会通过电报线——西联电报——它会告诉你发生了什么，你旁边放着一张录有观众喧闹声的唱片，然后你描述发生了什么，当然最棒的地方在于，它带有那种经典的——作为一个英国观察者来看——美国式的特质，那种夸大其词的热情，所以你会把比赛过程描述得尽可能激动人心、跌宕起伏。我的意思是，
the key to that, that anecdote was that he didn't want to break the spell. Yeah. He didn't want to let light in, you know, and, and that I think is, I don't think it's unfair to say that that is pretty key to his character.
那个轶事的关键在于，他不想打破这种魔咒。对。他不想让现实透进来，你知道的，我认为，说这是他性格中相当关键的一点，应该不算不公允吧。
Yeah. I mean, if, if there's a kind of a heartwarming fantasy, he doesn't want it punctured and indeed he goes on to kind of live it. Yeah. I think that's absolutely right. So if you think um you know boris johnson doing that i mean he would be quite good at it at first but he would be constantly winking at you and letting you know
对。我是说，如果有一种温馨的幻想，他是不希望被戳破的，事实上他接着就去过上了那种生活。对，我想这绝对没错。所以如果你想象一下，嗯，鲍里斯·约翰逊去做那事——我的意思是，他一开始会做得挺不错的，但他会不停地向你使眼色，让你知道……
that it's all hearing yeah that it's all that it's all a great joke and he actually has never seen any of the games because reagan lives it i mean and that's why he it why it's not so much a lie as a kind of exaggerated truth, perhaps one might say. Reagan is a great man for a parable, isn't he? For metaphorical truth, I suppose. He really believes in that. So anyway, the baseball is great work. It's great training. He does it six days a week.
这一切都是闹着玩的，对吧，这一切都只是个巨大的玩笑，而且他其实从来没看过任何比赛——而里根是真心投入其中。我的意思是，这就是为什么与其说这是一个谎言，不如说它是一种夸大的真相，也许人们会这么说。里根很擅长讲寓言，对吧？为了某种隐喻式的真相，我想。他真的深信不疑。不管怎样，棒球是份很棒的工作。这是极好的锻炼。他一周做六天。
He'll do 160 games in a given summer. And he's talking, isn't he, to listeners? I mean, that's the other thing. He can talk to people as though it's a one-on-one chat to a friend. Yeah. At a time when Roosevelt is doing his fireside chats to sell the New Deal to people. So radio is the medium through which you communicate. And Reagan, he's a local celebrity in Des Moines.
在特定的夏天，他要解说160场比赛。他在跟听众说话，对吧？我的意思是，还有一件事：他可以像跟朋友一对一聊天那样跟人们说话。对。当时罗斯福正在进行他的“炉边谈话”，向人们推销新政。所以广播是沟通的媒介。而里根，他是得梅因当地的名人。
So he's the kind of person who is a well enough known radio personality that they'll have his his picture behind the bar in the local bar people say oh dutch reagan comes here um and meanwhile mugs mugs has gone off to france hasn't she she has she's um she's vanished yeah she's off the scene left she's off the scene readers of the sporting news voted him the fourth best sports announcer in the united states so he's this is often told as like a two-bit story he's in the middle of nowhere but he has millions and millions of listeners across the midwest so i think um the des moines dispatch said to millions of sports fans in at least seven or eight midwestern states the voice of dutch reagan is a daily source of baseball dope that's like how people talk about you tom history dope yeah that's good isn't it yeah history dope that's what we should have called the podcast yeah we should
所以他是那种足够知名的广播界人物，当地酒吧的吧台后面会挂着他的照片，人们会说：“哦，‘荷兰佬’里根来过这儿……”与此同时，姆格斯去了法国，不是吗？是的，她……她消失了。对，她退出了，她离开了，她退出了。体育新闻的读者投票评选他为全美第四佳体育播音员，所以——这常被当作一个小人物的故事来讲述，他身处偏远小镇，但在中西部他拥有数以百万计的听众。所以我想，嗯，《得梅因快报》曾说过，对于中西部至少七八个州的数百万体育迷来说，“荷兰佬”里根的声音是每日棒球内幕消息的来源——这就像人们谈论你一样，汤姆，历史内幕消息。对，这挺好，不是吗？对，历史内幕消息，我们早该把播客叫这个名字。对，我们应该这么做的。
but so he could easily have done that he could easily have done that all his life and and gone down as a much like you know retired in the 1970s or 80s as a much-loved local. Would have been played by Kevin Costner in a mid-90s film. Maybe he would. Yeah, Dutch Reagan, the greatest sportscaster. But that's not enough for him. He goes off with the Cubs in 1936 when they're spring training in California. And then a year later, he goes again. And he has a friend that he's met through WHO.
但他本可以轻易做到这一点，他本可以一辈子都这么做，然后像许多……你知道的，在20世纪70年代或80年代退休，成为一个备受爱戴的当地名人。本来可能会由凯文·科斯特纳在90年代中期的电影里扮演。也许他会吧。对，“荷兰佬”里根，最伟大的体育解说员。但对她来说这还不够。1936年，当芝加哥小熊队在加利福尼亚进行春训时，他跟着去了。一年后，他又去了。他通过WHO结识了一位朋友。
He's called Joy Hodges, who's an actress and singer. And they have dinner. And he says, he just comes straight out with it and says i would love to be in hollywood you know he's in his mid-20s of course he would you know i'd love to of course he would and and she calls her agent who's got who's called bill michael john and her agent meets him and says yeah he could do it he's tall he's handsome says, I mean, Reagan does have a magnificent voice. He has the most wonderful, sonorous, warm voice. And he's also, all his lifeguarding, he's a very good swimmer. Yeah.
她叫乔·霍奇斯，是一名女演员和歌手。他们一起吃了晚餐。他说，他开门见山地说，我特别想去好莱坞，你知道，他当时二十多岁，他当然想去了，你知道的，我当然想去了，然后她打电话给她的经纪人，名叫比尔·迈克尔约翰，她的经纪人见了他，说：“行，他能行，他又高又帅。”我是说，里根确实有一副宏亮的嗓音。他有着最美妙、最洪亮、最温暖的嗓音。而且他由于当过救生员，是个非常出色的游泳运动员。对。
So he's got the physique. Yeah. And he's a very good looking man. He is. He's got everything. I mean, this agent, Bill Michaeljohn, he basically takes one look at him and he rings Warner Brothers and says, I have another Robert Taylor for you. And they do a screen test and they offer him a seven year deal. Warner's office contract, seven years, stop one year option, stop starting two hundred dollars a week.
所以他有很好的体形。对。而且他是个长相非常英俊的男人。他确实是。他具备了一切条件。我是说，这个经纪人比尔·迈克尔约翰，基本上看他一眼就给华纳兄弟打了个电话，说：“我给你们找到另一个罗伯特·泰勒了。”他们安排了一场银幕试镜，并给他提供了一份为期七年的合同。华纳的官方合同，七年，一年期选项停止，起薪每周二百美元。
Stop. Yeah. And Reagan says famously bite the hand off before they change their mind. That's sort of nice little bit of self-deprecation kind of that he's very good at. That's quite that's a lot of money. I the conversion that's 10 in today's money that's about ten thousand um dollars a week it's not bad so that's not bad at all he's a big enough fellow in the midwest that um who throw him a farewell party and the mayor of des moines goes the state treasurer of iowa yeah so he's not a nobody at all no and then he goes off to hollywood and by hollywood standards he's not he's never a really big star so he's got a contract. If you had a contract with Warner Brothers, you're one of about 100 people of whom maybe 20 to 30 are the big stars and the 70 others who are the kind of contract players. So he's always B-movie basically.
停。对。正如里根那句名言所说：“在他们改变主意之前，赶紧答应下来。”这体现了他那种很好、很谦逊的自我贬低，这是他非常擅长的。这真的是一大笔钱。我换算了一下，按今天的币值大约相当于每周一万美元，相当不错。所以这真的很不错。他在中西部算是个大人物了，WHO为他举办了一场告别派对，得梅因市长也去了，爱荷华州财政也去了，对。所以他根本不是个无名小卒。不，然后他去了好莱坞，以好莱坞的标准来看，他从来算不上真正的大明星。所以他签的是合同。如果你跟华纳兄弟签了合同，你只是大约100名演员中的一个，这其中或许有20到30个大明星，另外70个则是所谓的合同演员。所以他基本上总是演B级片。
Yeah. And he's always the best friend. He is always the best friend. So the Gipper, I mean, the Gipper isn't the lead in the film, is it? No, he's not. It's a sad moment when the Gipper dies, but the film is about Knut Rockne. It's about the coach. So, yeah, he works six days a week, five in the morning till six o'clock in the evening.
对。而且他总是演男主角的好朋友。他总是演好朋友。所以“吉普·吉普森”——我是说，“吉普”并不是电影里的主角，对吧？不，他不是。当“吉普”死去时，这是一个悲伤的时刻，但这部电影是关于克努特·罗克内的。它是关于教练的。所以，是的，他一周工作六天，从早上五点一直干到晚上六点。
But he's lucky because he has a friend, because the big gossip columnist of the day, Luella Parsons, who writes for the Los Angeles Examiner, one of the Hearst stable of papers, she is from Dixon, Illinois. So she takes a real shine to Reagan and boosts him up. It's the Midwest Mafia. Exactly. Yeah, the Dixon Mafia. People never talk about them controlling Hollywood, do they?
但他很幸运，因为他有一个朋友，当时的顶级八卦专栏作家卢埃拉·帕森斯，她为赫斯特旗下的《洛杉矶审查报》撰稿，她是伊利诺伊州迪克森人。所以她对里根非常青睐，并极力捧红他。这就是中西部黑手党。完全正确。对，迪克森黑手党。人们从不谈论他们控制了好莱坞，对吧？
So, yeah, he's doing all these sort of B-movies. So they're about one hour long i mean unbelievably he plays custer does he play custer he does uh opposite errol flynn who's playing jeb stewart and errol flynn will then go on to play custer two years later and they died with their boots on and errol flynn looks much more like custer reagan's the last person he doesn't have a beard he doesn't have a moustache he doesn't have the beard. He doesn't have a moustache. He doesn't have the long golden curls. I mean, he looks nothing like Custer. And his personality is always the sort of sturdy, reliable, loyal, decent, the soul of the American Midwest. That's what he plays.
所以，是的，他拍了所有这些B级片。它们大约只有一小时长。难以置信的是，他还演过卡斯特。他演过卡斯特吗？他演过，搭档是饰演杰布·斯图尔特的埃罗尔·弗林，两年后埃罗尔·弗林自己也在《群雄浴血战》里演了卡斯特，而埃罗尔·弗林看起来比卡斯特更像卡斯特。里根是最后一个人选，他没有胡子，他没有髭须。他没有胡须。他没有八字胡。他也没有长长的金色卷发。我是说，他长得一点也不像卡斯特。而他的银幕形象总是那种坚定、可靠、忠诚、正派的美国中西部灵魂。这就是他扮演的角色。
And Custer doesn't really fit that description. No, not at all. So that's miscasting. And then he plays a guy who loses his legs, doesn't he? In King's Row. That's his most... Where's the rest of me? Yeah.
而卡斯特与这个描述并不太相符。不，一点也不。所以这是选角失误。然后他演了一个失去双腿的人，对吧？在《克林斯堡》中。这是他最……“我的身体其余部分在哪儿？”对。
So actually, his two most famous moments both involve him lying down. They're lying. Yeah. Kind of throat infections, lost limbs. Gorbachev had watched King's Row. Had he? Yeah. And so when they met in Geneva and Reagan was saying to Gorbachev, actually, you know,
所以实际上，他最著名的两个时刻都涉及他躺在地上。他们躺着。对。喉部感染、失去肢体。戈尔巴乔夫看过《克林斯堡》。看过吗？对。所以当他们在日内瓦会面时，里根对戈尔巴乔夫说，其实，你知道的……
everyone says that I was just a kind of not a very important actor, but I was quite famous. And Gorbachev said, yes, I saw you played someone who didn't have any legs. What a bizarre. Brilliant, isn't it? I mean, he was. So the thing with Reagan and acting, I mean, it's so many people have poured over this. He was he was never a kind of a-list big name he was always a supporting actor people would sort of say especially in the 80s when
每个人都说我只是个不太重要的演员，但我其实挺有名的。戈尔巴乔夫说：“是的，我看到你演了一个没有腿的人。”多么离奇。太精彩了，不是吗？我是说，他确实如此。所以里根与表演的关系，我是说，有太多人对此进行了深入研究。他从来不是那种A级大牌明星，他总是扮演配角。人们常常会说，尤其是到了20世纪80年代，
people were his critics would say he was a terrible actor b-movie actor i mean he wasn't terrible otherwise he wouldn't have wouldn't have got the contract he wouldn't have got the contract but also he he raises his profile in two ways doesn't he so he the first is um and this is where the gossip column comes in that he he marries jane wyman yeah the time they start going out together their careers are about on a par but in due course she i mean she'll win an oscar she'll become which is nominated for an oscar yeah i think she wins an oscar in due course after the war oh you're absolutely right you're right and i stand she doesn't just get an oscar she's got two golden glows and two Remy's.
他的批评者会说他是个糟糕的演员、B级片演员。我是说，他并不糟糕，否则他不会得到合同，他不会拿到合同。但同时，他也通过两种方式提升了自己的知名度，不是吗？首先是——这就是八卦专栏发挥作用的地方——他娶了简· Wyman。对。他们刚开始交往时，各自的演艺事业可以说不相上下。但不久之后，她——我的意思是，她将赢得奥斯卡奖，她将成为……她曾获得奥斯卡提名，对。我想她后来在战后赢得了一奥斯卡奖。噢，你说得对，你说得对，我收回前言。她不只拿了一座奥斯卡，她还拿了两个金球奖和两个……
Yeah, so she ends up a massive star. And I think that becomes part of the problem because, of course, spoiler alert, Reagan and Jane Wyman end up divorcing.
对，所以她最终成了一个超级巨星。我认为这也成了问题的一部分，因为，当然了——剧透警告——里根和简· Wyman最终离婚了。
And it's Jane Wyman who wants to do it. And I think that the kind of disequilibrium between the parabola of their respective careers is part of that. But Jane Wyman
而且是简· Wyman主动提出的。我认为他们各自事业发展轨迹的失衡是其中的一部分原因。但简· Wyman……
has a very kind of Marilyn Monroe-esque confusion of names, kind of broken upbringing. And she and Reagan, that's a kind of great partnership because the gossip columnists can write about it and all that kind of thing. But they're very ill-suited though, aren't they, Tom? Incredibly ill-suited. I'm so bored with him, I'll either kill him or kill myself, she says at one point.
有着非常玛丽莲·梦露式的身世困惑和破碎的成长经历。她和里根曾是一对绝佳的伴侣，八卦专栏作家可以大肆报道他们，诸如此类。但他们其实非常不般配，不是吗，汤姆？极其不般配。“我对腻了他，要么杀了要么自杀算了，”她曾在某个时刻说道。
And she's always complaining about his um his verbal diarrhea she just says what did she say to him at one point when they when they um break up it's actually uh i'm just going to try and find the quotation i came here hoping you'd changed but you haven't you're still the same loud mouth you were because because by this point reagan has discovered reed's digest yeah and he just motors his way through it and he will just repeat it. And so he's endlessly going on to Jane Wyman about dams in Africa and ocelots and all kinds of stuff. Is he talking about ocelots? I don't, surely not. That's the kind of thing you get in Reader's Digest.
她总是抱怨他的那些“语言腹泻”。她到底对他说过什么来着？当他们……分手时。其实……我正要找找那句引言：“我来这里是希望你变了，但你没有，你还是那个满嘴大话的家伙，就像以前一样。”因为到了这个时候，里根已经发现了《读者文摘》，对。他只是机械地翻阅它，然后不停地重复里面的内容。所以他总是对简· Wyman滔滔不绝地讲非洲的大坝、豹猫以及各种各样的东西。他在谈论豹猫吗？我不知道，绝对不可能吧。那是你在《读者文摘》里能读到的那种东西。
He's full of facts. Everybody always says, and they say this right through to 1980 january 1989 when he leaves the white house they say the trouble with reagan is if you write something down and hand it to him he will believe it i mean all his aides say it drives them mad that he reads stuff in magazines and is so there's one famous example where he says that trees cause more pollution than yes people do and he's read it somewhere and It's in the Reader's Digest. And he cannot be persuaded that it's not true. But the thing that's interesting about Jane Wyman
他满脑子都是事实。每个人都这么说，而且他们一直这么说到1980年、1989年1月他离开白宫的时候。他们说，里根的问题在于，如果你把什么东西写下来交给他，他就会深信不疑。我是说，他所有的助手都这么说，这让他们快要发疯了：他在杂志上读到一些东西，于是……有个著名的例子：他说树木造成的污染比人类还要多，对。他是从哪儿看来的。它就在《读者文摘》里。而且你根本无法说服他这不是真的。但关于简· Wyman，有趣的是……
is that she was always a Republican. So Reagan was the liberal and she was the conservative. And so actually, long after they've divorced, she votes for him in both elections. And Dominic, here's a link um to the cathars episode perhaps unexpected okay this is unexpected so when she died she was buried in the uh the white robes of a dominican nun so she was a dominican buried at redler chateau no she wasn't that would be a heck of a twist who knows what truth maybe she was a a grand mistress of the priory of zion but she's completely wrong
她一直是个共和党人。所以里根曾是个自由派，而她是保守派。事实上，在他们离婚很久之后，她在两次大选中都把票投给了他。多米尼克，这里有一个联系，嗯……通往卡特派教徒的那集，或许挺出人意料的。好吧，这确实出人意料：她去世时，身上穿的是多明尼加修女的白色长袍入殓的。所以她是个多明尼加修女，埋葬在……雷德勒城堡？不，她不是。那可真是一个巨大的反转。谁知道真相是什么呢，也许她曾是锡安修道院的大女大师？但她完全不是这样。
she's very fiery she's um she's sort of quite a turbulent character yes she's typecast as a kind of you know she's in screwball comedies she's a kind of wisecracking dame that kind of stuff she's a floozy she's a floozy is what she is and and she wants to get out of that and play more complicated more yeah subtle characterization and she succeeds in doing that reagan never does that and i think part of it is that maybe he's a more limited actor but i think also it's because actually he can't play more complex characters because he's not a particularly complicated character do you think yeah is that harsh i don't think no i think that's right i think lots of people say about him he only basically plays himself hal wallace of runs the warner slate so he's in charge of managing the sort of the warner team he says he's not an actor of depth or intensity yeah and
她非常火爆，她……她是一个相当桀骜不驯的人物。是的，她被定型为那种……你知道的，她演过疯喜剧，她是个妙语连珠的泼辣妇人，诸如此类。她是个放荡的女人。她就是个放荡的女人。她想摆脱这种形象，去扮演更复杂、更……微妙的角色，她成功做到了。里根从未做到这一点。我认为部分原因在于，也许他是个局限性更大的演员，但我也认为，那是因为他根本无法扮演更复杂的角色，因为他本身就不是一个特别复杂的人物，你觉得呢？是吗？这样说太苛刻了吗？我不觉得，不，我觉得这很对。很多人都这么评价他，他基本上只在演他自己。华纳电影公司的负责人哈尔·华莱士——也就是负责管理华纳团队的人——他说：“他不是一个有深度或有强度的演员。”对，而且……
lots of people basically say ronald reagan will play the best friend but anything more demanding anything more subtle so actually in king's row where he loses his legs he had hoped that would be the springboard to playing more you know more uh demanding parts but that's 1941 the war intervenes and there's a bit of a hiatus in his career because he goes off to join the air corps that's when he does a lot of his readers digest reading because he's he's sort of working as a backroom boy he's too old really to fight. He has a dependence by that point. So Jane and they've started a family. So Maureen, and then they end up adopting Michael.
很多人基本上都说，罗纳德·里根只会演好朋友，任何更高要求、更细腻的东西……所以实际上，在《克林斯堡》中他失去双腿时，他曾希望那会成为他出演更多、你知道的、更多有挑战性角色的跳板。但那是1941年，战争爆发了，他的演艺生涯出现了一段空档，因为他去参军了。正是在那个时候，他读了大量的《读者文摘》，因为他当时在后方做内勤工作，实际上他的年纪已经太大而无法参战了。当时他有家室了。所以简和他们已经有了个家庭。先是莫琳，然后他们收养了迈克尔。
But again, the weird thing, so there's this brilliant comment by Stephen Vaughan on Reagan, that no 20th century president, with the exception of Dwight D. Eisenhower, had been seen in uniform by more people. Because he's appearing in all these propaganda films. Because he's appearing in propaganda films yeah so he's he's kind of playing a simulacrum of an american officer in the war yes he is he does it so brilliantly
但同样奇怪的是，斯蒂芬·沃恩对里根有一个精彩的评价：20世纪没有任何一位总统——除了德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔之外——曾穿过制服被如此多的人看到过。因为他出现在所有这些宣传片里。因为他出现在宣传片里，对，所以他有点像是在战争中扮演一个美国军官的幻影。是的，他确实如此。他演得如此出色，
that it comes to seem indistinguishable from from the reality well i mean it's reagan who institutes for example saluting uh when he's president always saluting um the marine guards and all these kinds of things he's brilliant saturn he looks very military but he's president, always saluting the Marine Guards and all these kinds of things. He's brilliant, and he looks very military. But he's always quite conscious, I think, that he didn't see action in the Second World War, that actually he spent it behind a desk through no fault of his own. I mean, among other things, his short-sightedness means that he would probably have found it very hard to get a sort of front line. Well, I think when we come to the account of his,
以至于它看起来与现实难分真假。好吧，我是说，正是里根开创了——例如，当他成为总统时，总是向海军陆战队卫兵敬礼，诸如此类的事情。他非常出色，看起来很有军人风范。但他心里其实一直挺清楚的，自己并没有在第二次世界大战中亲历战火，而是阴差阳错地在办公桌后度过了那段时光。我是说，除此之外，他的近视意味着他可能很难上前线。好吧，我想当我们讲到关于他的……
the assassination attempt on him, it will be very clear that Reagan was certainly not a coward. No, no, no, not at all. I mean, he was a very brave man. But again, it's this bleeding of reality into fantasy and back again and role-playing. So that it kind of becomes indistinguishable. But one thing, so I talked about the two
那次对他的暗杀未遂时，就会非常清楚地表明，里根绝对不是一个懦夫。不，不，不，一点也不是。我是说，他是一个非常勇敢的人。但同样的，这也是现实融入幻想、再次循环并进行角色扮演的过程。以至于它们变得无法区分。不过有一件事——我刚才说过让里根知名度提升的两个原因，尽管他的演艺生涯并不算星光熠熠。其一是与简· Wyman的婚姻。另一个是，他开始涉足好莱坞政治，不是吗？特别是工会政治。话说回来，里根是唯一一个——我想是唯一一个曾担任过工会领袖的美国总统。我想这绝对没错。是的。他退伍归来后，对他的那种角色的需求实际上正在枯竭。因为在20世纪40年代末，人们想要冲突更多、更接地气的电影。而他显然不适合这种风格。他是30年代那种情节剧的风格。他不合拍。于是他全身心投入到美国演员工会中。他一直……我是说，这再次反映了他最深层的冲动。
things that raise Reagan's profile, despite the fact that his acting career isn't entirely stellar. So one is his marriage to Jane Wyman. The other is that he starts to get into Hollywood politics, doesn't he? And specifically union politics. And again, so Reagan is the only, I think, the only US president to have been a union leader. I think that's absolutely right. Yes. He comes out of the war and the demand for his kind of parts is drying up actually. Because in the late 1940s, people want more conflicted, grittier films. And he's just not right for that. He's from the late 30s, melodramas. He doesn't fit. And he throws himself into the Screen Actors Guild. He's always been... I mean, this is, again, this is something that reflects his deepest impulses.
回想他小时候和他的母亲以及基督门徒会，你总是要融入其中。所以从1938年左右开始，在他拍的大多数电影里，他一直都是工会代表、工会监督员。他是个工会人。而且他干得很好，非常受欢迎。是的，他很受欢迎。但在20世纪40年代末，好莱坞的工会政治非常、非常充满冲突。所以有一连串的罢工。
Going back to his mother when he's growing up and the Disciples of Christ, you always join in. So he'd always been the union rep, the union monitor from about 1938 onwards on most of the films he had done. He was a union man. And does it well and is very popular. Yeah, he's very popular. But Hollywood union politics is very, very conflicted in the late 1940s. So there are a whole series of strikes.
制片厂老板们正向右翼靠拢。所以像华特·迪士尼这样的人，真的在极力鼓吹反共主义。部分原因在于他们对罢工非常生气，基本上想把罢工描绘成受到共产主义煽动的结果。1946年有一个关键时刻。主角不是演员本身。而是那些搭建布景的人……
The studio bosses are swinging to the right. So people like Walt Disney, for example, are really, really banging the drum of anti-communism. And in part because they're very cross about the strikes and they basically want to present the strikes as communist inspired. There is a key moment from 1946. It's not the actors themselves. It is the people who build the sets
做各种……是的，做所有苦力活的人。他们一直由一个叫国际戏剧和舞台雇员联盟的组织代表，但有一个分裂出去的工会叫工作室工会联合会，偏向左翼的演员们渴望支持这个工会，这场争端变得相当恶劣。因此，在1946年9月，1000多名油漆工、装饰工、建筑工等被解雇了。问题是，演员们将支持谁？
and do all the sort of- Yeah, do all the hard graft. So they've been represented by something called the international alliance of theatrical and stage employees but there's a breakaway union called the conference of studio unions um that the sort of the left the more left-leaning actors are keen to back uh this dispute gets really quite vicious. So September 1946, more than 1,000 of the sort of painters and decorators and builders and things are fired. And the question is, who are the actors going to back,
是制片厂老板还是手艺人？1946年10月，里根在一个能容纳6000人的体育场里向所有好莱坞演员发表了一场大型主题演讲，他在演讲中说服他们，这场罢工是由共产党领导的，他们不应该卷入其中。此后他得到了警察的保护，对吧？因为有人威胁要往他脸上泼泼酸。没错。
the studio bosses or the craftsmen? And Reagan delivers a big set piece speech in a 6,000-seater stadium to all the Hollywood actors, basically, in October 1946, in which he persuades them that the strike is being led by communists and they shouldn't get involved. He gets police protection after that, doesn't he? Because it's a threat that acid will be thrown in his face. Exactly.
那是一个充斥着肮脏政治的充满冲突的时期。众议院非美活动调查委员会正在调查好莱坞，向好莱坞施压，称你们在二战期间制作了太多亲苏电影。有太多共产党作家。人们怀疑好莱坞内部存在共产党细胞，诸如此类。1947年3月，当这一切变得非常、非常白热化的时候，里根成为了美国演员工会的会长。他对自己的角色没有任何怀疑。在他看来，他的角色就是捍卫美国价值观，与非美活动调查委员会合作，与联邦调查局合作。但，我是说——他变得非常公开地反共，但与此同时，他在代表同行演员对抗制片厂老板的利益时也非常有效，对吧？我是说，从这个程度上讲，他依然非常明显地带有富兰克林·罗斯福的信徒、崇拜者、他父亲的儿子的烙印。
It's a very conflicted time of dirty politics. The House Committee on Un-American Activities are looking into Hollywood, putting pressure on Hollywood, saying, you've made far too many pro-Soviet films in World War II. There are far too many communist writers. There's this suspicion of a communist cell within Hollywood and so on and so forth. And Reagan becomes the president of the Screen Actors Guild in March 1947, at the point at which all this is really, really hotting up. And he has no doubt whatsoever about his role. His role, as he sees it, is to stand up for the American way, to cooperate with HUAC, cooperate with the FBI. But, I mean, so he's becoming, becoming i mean very openly anti-communist but at the same time he is very effective at representing the interests of his fellow actors against the studio bosses right i mean he's to that extent he's still very recognizably the the disciple of f, the admirer, his father's son.
是的，他依然在投民主党的票。所以他依然在投票支持FDR。我想他在1948年肯定也是投了杜鲁门的票。他对制片厂老板并不具对抗性。他总是会和他们达成交易。但他很受欢迎……对，在其他演员中间很受欢迎。那些拥有投票权的演员认为他很有能力。
Yeah, he's still voting Democrat. So he's still voting for FDR. He's, I guess, must vote for Truman in 1948. He's not confrontational with the studio bosses. So he would always cut deals with them. But he's popular with- Yeah, with the other actors. With the other actors who vote because they see him as effective.
对，你完全说得对。他们绝对不把他视为制片厂老板的傀儡。我认为后来确实有人质疑他是否与自己的经纪公司MCA走得太近。那是一家非常强大的好莱坞经纪公司。但你完全说得对。如果他没有被视为一个愿意为演员争取更好待遇而战的人，他是不会被推到演员工会主席这个位置上的。悬在他头上的问号是，他在1947年底去非美活动调查委员会作证等等。
Yeah, you're absolutely right. They definitely don't regard him as the studio boss's puppet. I think there are definitely questions later on about whether he's a little bit too close to his own agency, MCA. It's a really powerful Hollywood agency. But you're absolutely right. He would not have been propelled into that position as the head of the Screen Actors Guild had he not been regarded as a guy who will fight for a better deal for the actors. The question mark that hangs over him is he goes and testifies to HUAC and so on and so forth in late 1947.
他的做法非常典型里根。他非常擅长取悦所有人，给所有人面子，所以他走到委员会面前说，嗯，好莱坞确实有一些共产党人，但他没有点名任何人，他说有一些共产党人，但我们已经把他们控制住了，你知道的，我们会把他们斩草除根，因为他试图在保护……他一边给委员会想要的东西，一边又在保护演员工会，保护绝大多数演员。所以正是在这个时候，出现了“好莱坞十君子”的黑名单。那些不愿配合调查的人被列入黑名单，只能用假名工作之类。
What he does is it's classic Reagan. He's brilliant at pleasing everybody giving everybody so he goes in front of the committee and he says well there are some communists in hollywood but he doesn't name any names he says there are communists um but we've got them under control you know we'll root them out because he's sort of trying to protect his simultaneously giving the committee what it wants while also protecting the screen actors guild Guild and protecting the great majority of actors. So this is the point at which you have the blacklist of the Hollywood 10. Those people who won't cooperate with the inquiry, they are put on a blacklist and they can only work under false names and stuff.
里根对声援他们毫无兴趣，有些人会这么做。他绝对不会冒这个险去那样做。但他走了一条路线——这不能算是一个折中的路线，因为他的反共立场变得越来越鲜明。但我认为，如果说他只是个狂热的“红帽子”或别的什么，那未免有失公允，正如后来的批评者有时所说的那样。但在整个50年代，他确实在向右倾斜。所以反共主义与他对税收负担的不满结合在了一起。因为是不是有这么一回事……
Reagan has no interest in standing up for them, which some people do. He's absolutely not going to go out on a limb to do that. But he's sort of charted, it's not quite a middle course because his anti-communism is becoming increasingly sort of marked. But I think it would be unfair to say he's just a sort of rabid red bait or something, as later critics sometimes did. But over the course of the 50s, he is definitely drifting to the right. So anti-communism is combined with a resentment of the tax burden as he sees it. Because isn't there
他曾期望战后能有一次税收特赦，但没有得到？没错。人们在一战时有过这种待遇。退伍军人曾能够将他们的税收推迟到战争结束。要么他在《读者文摘》里读到过，要么他有个非常糟糕的会计告诉他，他们这次可能也会这么做。所以他没有交税。基本上这就迫使他在二战结束时落入了最高的税率等级。他对此感到暴怒。而且，简· Wyman向他提出了离婚。所以他必须支付她的赡养费，因为她得到了孩子。而且他的事业也开始走下坡路了。没错。
something to do with he'd expected a tax amnesty after the war, which he didn't get? That's right. People had had them in World War I. Veterans had been able to defray their taxes to the end of the war. Either he's read in the Reader's Digest or he's got a very bad accountant who says they'll probably do the same again. So he doesn't pay his taxes. And then basically that forces him into the highest possible tax bracket at the end of World War II. And he's outraged. He's also, Jane Wyman has asked him for a divorce. So he's paying alimony to her because she gets the kids. And his career is starting to go down. Exactly.
没错。他的事业开始走下坡路了。此外，他周围开始聚集了许多极右翼的演员。所以罗伯特·泰勒、罗伯特·蒙哥马利、乔治·墨菲，他们是一群到了一定年纪的演员。他们可能比里根大几岁。他们看起来有点像里根。他们经常坐在一起……
Exactly. His career is starting to go down. Plus, he's sort of hanging around with a lot of actors who are very right wing. So Robert Taylor, Robert Montgomery, George Murphy, they're kind of actors of a certain age. They're maybe a couple of years older than Reagan. They kind of look like Reagan. They sort of sit around.
天哪。是的，是的。抹了大量的发蜡。他们坐在一起喝着苏士忌，抱怨交税太多，抱怨游泳池。你认为在里根的例子中，随着他的事业似乎在走下坡路，这是他的政治立场首次源于某种怨恨吗？他永远无法理解为什么他的电影事业不成功。我想他一直认为自己是个更好的演员，而且他从来没有真正得到一个……这就是为什么后来当别人嘲笑他的演技时，他会非常敏感。他自己不介意这么做，
Cracky. Yeah. Yeah. Sort of a lot of broil cream. They sit around drinking scotch and sort of moaning about paying too much tax and the swimming pool. Do you think in Reagan's case, as his career seems to be going down, that for the first time is his politics being bred of resentment, do you think? He can never understand why his film career doesn't work out. I think he always thinks he was a better actor and he never really got a... That's why he's very prickly later on when people mock his acting. He doesn't mind doing it himself,
但他不喜欢别人这么做。这倒也合情合理。我能感同身受。哦，你对很多事情也是这样的。是的，不，我确实有同感。不，我觉得你是对的。某种意义上，人生的这个阶段是他一生中第一次没有得到一切想要的……雄心壮志和努力工作并没有把他带到他以为能去的地方，而且要重申的是，它们确实已经把他带得很远了。哦，是的。
but he doesn't like other people doing it. Fair enough. I can relate to that. Oh, you're like that about, you know, a lot a lot of things yeah no i i certain fellow feeling yeah no i think i think you're right i think there's a sense in which life at this point is the first point in his in his life where he's not getting everything you know ambition and hard work and not taking him to the places yeah that he thought they would and just to reiterate i mean they have taken him a very long way. Oh, yeah.
他出身于一个非常贫困的背景，他可以说是一直在过着美国梦，但现在的美国梦正在微微变质。是的。所以他的电影事业正走向终点，那么问题来了，他要做什么呢？好吧，当我们下次回来时，我们要谈谈那个他还没见过的人，
He's from a very poverty-stricken background, and he kind of has been living the American dream, but the American dream now is slightly curdling. Yes. And so his film career is coming to an end, and so therefore the question is, what is he going to do? Well, when we come back next time, we'll talk about the one person who he hasn't yet met,
这个人肯定会坚定他向右转的立场，她绝不是出身于贫困背景，这个人当然就是南茜——南茜·戴维斯，她后来成了他伟大的灵魂伴侣和伴侣。但在我们收尾之前，汤姆，里根人生的最低谷：他在1940年初去了伦敦。那是他去过的第一个外国，对吧？他觉得那儿糟透了。
who definitely is going to confirm his move to the right, who is not from a poverty-stricken background by any means, and that is, of course, Nancy, Nancy Davis, who becomes his great sort of soulmate and his partner. But just before we bow out, Tom, I mean, the lowest point in Reagan's life, he goes to London in early 1940. It's the first foreign country he's ever been to, isn't it? And he thinks it's terrible.
这印证了他对社会主义的所有阴暗猜想。他对克莱门特·艾德礼的英国的社会主义感到震惊。你知道他是怎么形容伦敦的吗？一片荒凉的荒野，汤姆。这就是我对伦敦的感觉。所以，你知道的，他让人空运了一些牛排到萨伏伊酒店，因为他觉得英国的食物太难吃了。平心而论，
It confirms all his darker suspicions of socialism. He's shocked by the socialism of Clement Attlee's Britain. Do you know what he described London as? A dismal wilderness, Tom. That's how I feel about London. So, you know, he had some stakes flown over to the Savoy because he thought the British food was so bad. To be fair
对我们来说，那是因为我们刚被轰炸过，而且……他有一次对他的联合主演理查德·托德说，“什么是配给制？”他简直无法理解。他让人空运了这些牛排过来，但萨伏伊酒店的冰箱显然没有正常运作，所以牛排最后全都变质了。是的，那……这印证了他对欧洲式社会主义和集体主义的所有最黑暗的恐惧。幸好他的曾曾祖父母当时没有留在佩卡姆，对吧？是的。哦，天哪，是的。躲过一劫。那可真算是躲过一劫。
to us though that's because we've been bombed and uh what he says to richard todd his co-star at one point what is rationing he kind of can't get his head around it he has these steaks flown over but the fridges in the savoy apparently didn't work properly so the steaks all went bad anyway yeah that's um that confirms all his darkest fears about European style socialism and social. It's lucky his great, great grandparents didn't stay in Peckham then, isn't it? Yeah. Well, gosh, yes. A bullet dodged. That is a bullet dodged.
好啦。我们会回来的，并且会多聊聊南茜。我们会谈谈里根去通用电气工作的经历、他在1964年参与巴里·戈德华特竞选活动、当选加州州长，然后是他的总统之路。在那之后，我们将进入总统任期、戈德华特、伊朗门事件，所有这些事情。所以我们大概要看三集，对吧？哦，肯定的，汤姆。
Right. We will come back and we will be talking a bit more about Nancy. We will talk about Reagan's move to work for General Electric, his involvement with the Barry Goldwater campaign in 1964, becoming governor of California, and then his rise to the presidency. And then after that, we will get on to the presidency, to Gorbachev, to Iran-Contra, all these things. So we're looking at three episodes, aren't we? Oh, definitely, Tom.
是的。至少三集。所以如果你现在就想听，好消息是其实你可以听。这是一个很棒的优惠。你应该用你的罗纳德·里根嗓音来推销这个。你想推销一下吗？他们在哪儿可以听到呢，汤姆？在哪个平台上？
Yeah. At least. So if you want to listen to them right now, the great news is that actually you can. It's a great offer. You should be selling this in your Ronald Reagan voice. Do you want to sell it? Where can they listen to them, Tom? On which platform?
我亲爱的美国同胞们，你们可以在所有平台上收听。这是一个超棒的优惠。所以你们要做的是，在Apple Podcasts或RestIsHistoryPod.com上订阅。Apple Podcasts或RestIsHistorypod.com。Apple Podcasts或restishistorypod.com。如果你不这么做，你就只能和那些欧洲式社会主义者一起苦等了。对。
My fellow Americans, they can listen to it on every platform. It's a great offer. So what you want to do is you want to subscribe on Apple Podcasts or RestIsHistoryPod.com. ApplePodcasts or RestIsHistorypod.com Apple Podcasts or restishistorypod.com And if you don't do that, you'll just have to wait along with the European style socialists. Yeah.
那是民主党的选项。对。你就只能等着。如果你是一群失败的共产主义笨蛋，你就只能等着。别付钱给我们。我把自己看作是……在这个类比里我是谁，嗯……你是谁？你是……你是南茜？我不是南茜，我正要说我不是南茜，我是……我是像莱缪尔·布尔沃那样的人。
That's the Democrat option. Yeah. You'll just have to wait. If you're a bunch of loser commies, you'll just have to wait. Don't pay us money. I see myself very much as the... Who am I in this analogy um who are you you're what you're nancy i'm not nancy i was just about to say i'm not nancy i'm i'm somebody like lemuel bull wear
来自通用电气。所以你们绝对应该去注册，因为老实说，接下来登场的一连串名字荒谬离奇的角色绝对不容错过。所以，赶快加入吧，赶快加入吧！所以下一次，莱缪尔·布尔沃的人生与职业生涯，就在《历史的其余部分》，当然还有一些关于罗纳德·里根的内容。再见！再见！
of general electric so you definitely want to go and sign up because honestly the list of characters with ludicrous and improbable names coming up is not to be missed so basically pile in pile in so next time the life and career of lemuel bulware on the rest and also a bit of ronald reagan goodbye goodbye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。